yeah welcome to this video playing
Lauren's wrap the season doesn't have a
toddler but it's it's an FM I mean I
know a lauren sweat it's probably the
guy so it doesn't have it in there but
this is some I'm pretty good to feed a
master he's living in Germany so a
German flakis is some making sense ok we
gotta count pan off Bishop g5 I go nitey
for this somewhat wacky line that I also
made a video series on for the ICC it's
quite strange but this seems to be a an
interesting way to play for placket his
son plane quickly so maybe he knows
something about it ok Bishop f4 I don't
know that one but the question is is
there any good i mean ii six Bishop
before some is some difficult difficult
to meet wow yeah why not actually why
not okay
wait not so quick if i take the five you
will take e five and i'm completely
busted not not so fast
hmm interesting very interesting maybeee
six was wasn't so great I don't know it
looks and looks very dangerous for me
i'll wait i kept just plain ig6
sometimes sometimes you really think the
heck am I doing here then just 996 it's
just the good and easy move probably I
should should take a break or something
very easy to see this move but it took
me ages ok maybe we 5v5 crew takes f5
Queen moves f4i win the bishop yeah come
on that's let's do that
Queenie to f4 Bishop f4 great it's just
great sometimes hmm Jesus yeah so I
cannot do with that what else what can I
do here maybe this one if it takes a
threat anon hy nie self right now for it
looks that looks playable I mean I'm
just making things up as we go here
really bad game from my party okay so
take here I am gee I wonder if you can
take if I have maybe you can then rookie
woman
who doesn't want to
I'm not sure that this is so terrible of
like I mean I got my ball back don't
know maybe this is son this is a
playable
okay so he finally intends to capture
and play a form maybe I need to do that
you can just take it okay so castle some
need to get out of them
I can play a former this is not not a
big deal night c5 Bishop f5 is actually
a pretty substantial threat so
he needs to I thought you needed to take
it ok maybe he can do that it's not this
is possible I take this one this is this
is quite ok this is quite ok it can take
on c5 p.m.
and I'm down on the clock hmm you're not
that this is unusual just that I didn't
realize it before for this particular
game what
I don't know that's just just strange k
I want to get my looks active here and
just before I don't understand why why
would you weaken yourself p 5s the most
I like to play
take see far I can this was just saying
maybe rock f3 was even stronger I
considered it getting minted in the pin
but okay upon his upon
Oh
just grab everything everything that
they can take I will take
should c 5 would have been good getting
rooks off to get on the seventh what
would be would have been interesting i
came so now it's just a matter of time
if i if i manage or not check position
is relatively easy time morning unless
you give up your book which I was close
to do check check going from right now
check check check
check check check
check check check check check check
check in late drawn no no just one move
I did it actually said check major chick
made its at the hitting one headed
habitant idea ah very very close very
close yeah I for myself all of this I it
was at the beginning I really didn't I
didn't see any in remote lion I mean it
was terrible but ok right here it was it
was a fighting position where everything
else was possible a g4 was weird I mean
I could even take on e4 I saw that but I
wasn't sure that this is something 94
fe4 takes g forward I thought this would
put be good activating everything in
fact the computer agrees and it's good
here look at three years old soms
getting oops here looka three but ok
this was good I was only a bit a bit too
slow here ok thanks for watching